just remind us of the obligations that
tow operators have under the current
laws under the 99c director well under
the package tour regulations they are
liable if they fail to provide a holiday
that's in accordance with local safety
standards in those regulations are there
to make it easier for British
holidaymakers to receive compensation
when something goes wrong but in
practice Simon I mean we're talking
about hundreds thousands of hotels and
establishments and practice how easy is
it for two operators to ensure that
they're up to local standards not
perhaps of standards that are here well
that they are obliged to meet local
standards and from my estimation they do
a pretty good job given as you say the
vast scale and diversity of the travel
industry I've seen it indeed there with
thomas cook themselves the safety audit
that they carry out which covers
everything from the maintenance records
of the transfer bus that takes you from
the airport to the hotel to the
temperature of the fridges in the
kitchens they really are serious about
people's health and happiness on holiday
but I'm afraid in this case Thomas Cook
have made it look as though that there
are a bunch of bumbling amateurs who
have just worried about the blame game
and wanting to point a picture of it
there yet I mean in fairness that June
Chapman it does appear that in this case
I mean looking at the first instance of
some people killed due to wrong
maintenance at a hotel that you bought
through thomas cook it would appear to
the public that thomas cook ought to be
liable and yet that wasn't how it worked
out yes i agree with you that is the way
it ought to happen but unfortunately the
holiday companies do take a very
defensive attitude to these claims and
where they feel they can they they will
defend as much as they can even though
actually they're probably got in places
we've seen here contractual liabilities
back against the hotel who provided but
this I mean this did go to core people
were found guilty and Thomas Cook wasn't
you know they weren't in a corporate
sense but they did of course ultimately
settle the civil claim and given the
backlash we've seen since then Simon is
this a turning point for the industry do
you think I very much hope so I think
they've got to learn from the world's
safest industry globally which is
actually
aviation where there is a no blame
culture you investigate accidents to try
to stop them happening again you're not
looking at apportioning blame and that
is the best way to prevent a
reoccurrence and also I think the most
meaningful way to to remember the
victims by saying that this is helping
us to create a safer environment for
everybody what about the continued
employment of electricians and a manager
by hotel companies of people who were
found responsible for these actions I
mean does everyone who stayed in that
hotel as it were subsequently have some
kind of claim or complaint against out
of the hotel or the travel agent for
employing someone like that no I mean
it's absolutely shocking and you would
hope companies like this would actually
learn from their mistakes and rectify
them as soon as they've worked out
what's gone wrong but actually no one
else who stayed there subsequently is
entitled to any conversation because
nothing's happened to them there's no
weather victims I mean of course money
doesn't bring people back but one of the
things this brought up and sharp relief
is the fact that the damages that Thomas
Cook God from the hotel differ quite
sharply from what the family has got me
in bereavement damages surely there must
be some more action that can be taken
there oh well there there is and there
really should be action on this because
it is quite shocking I mean the
government sets the level of bereavement
damages it's currently twelve thousand
nine hundred and eighty pounds now that
is a very low sum of money when you
compare that with moderate injury claims
or even libel claims Ian it is it's
still true that it's cheaper to mainland
than to kill and it's it's cheaper to
kill someone than it is to libel that
person and that that is just wrong now
following the Germanwings accident we
see the German government starting to
move to increase compensation there for
brief families to 100,000 euros there
are higher walk awards in Scotland
already and this it really is something
our government ought to do something
about I thought abdur was supposed to
oversee all this and thought this sort
of thing happening why has it been in
all this well that they have that I mean
this is a terrible tragic event but it
happened nine years ago we do still see
very sadly tragedies occurring and and
the travel industry is absolutely
serious about dealing with them
including thomas cook but my goodness me
in years to come people will simply not
understand how the proudest name in
travel thomas cook could somehow turn
itself into a toxic brand by dealing
with the bereaved parents so badly like
you